As part of that.
There's definitely something to that.
And I think there's something to this
problem that human beings have, um,
where they,
they have an idea and that idea becomes
part of their identity and then they
start arguing for that idea.
And any argument against that idea is an
argument against them as a person cause
they're trying to win.
They're not necessarily looking at
things in an objective way where they're
detached from the idea and
studying it as a thing.
Instead they're arguing to try to win.
And I think that is a giant
problem with ideas. Yes.
And it becomes even more of a
problem when it gets tribal,
when these ideas are attached,
like climate change clearly attached in
denial to the right in support to the
left.
It's this very strange tribal thing.
And that also happens with gender.
And it also like if you are in support
of of women's rights and you are a in
support of trans rights and
Lbgtq and all that jazz,
you're almost a hundred percent
going to be on the left.
It's just one of those tribal things.
If you're pro choice,
you're almost always going to
be on the left. If you're not,
you find yourself in that. Which
one was it? Was it Tammy Lauren?
I get her confused with that.
Lauren southern girls.
Those girls are interchangeable in
some strange way. Those the, the,
the hot Republicans and Tomi Lahren,
Tomi Lahren, she's pro choice.
She got attacked. Can't be, can't
be. You want to be on this team.
You want to be on the,
the mean white girl team.
You can't be project you
gotta you gotta be prolife.
What about life but about the
babies support the bait. We,
you know what I'm saying? I was like,
some ideas get locked into ideologies.
They get locked into these
tribal ideologies and gender
is most certainly one of
those people don't want to be
without a political home. Right.
That's a very good way of
putting it because if you do say,
say someone like Tommy Tommy,
who is what our core Tammy,
cause I'm an asshole.
Oh, was she in trouble?
Tomi Lahren was star in
prolife film after the break.
The blaze fired her for being pro choice.
What?
So if you're a pro choice conservative
or if you're a pro biology liberal,
you know, you kind of find
yourself in a weird in between.
So she's just fucking going the other way.
She's going the other way.
She's going to start a film.
What's a pro life film?
It's like ABC after school special.
Don't have an abortion. Have you baby?
Yeah. Hmm. It's weird. Well
she's got to get her ground back.
Kicked off the team a little bit.
It's a bio pic on the Roe vs Wade
case starting Stacey Dash. Oh so,
so maybe she's playing a
bad person and that movie,
it just made it even more interesting.
Strange. I wonder how many of those
things are just distractions. You know,
it's so weird. People are
so weird with their, their,
their tribal identities, you know, I just,
and I love when they go back and forth
and shift from one side of the other.
I'd love it when like wow, former
conservative scene, the light or you know,
I used to be a liberal to the party,
lost me and I love that.
And then they go hardcore on the other
side is weird cause it's then everything
shifts is not just a couple of views.
It's everything in alignment with the
other side. How did you join the church?
Yup. Stop doing drugs. Yeah. It's
fascinating. It's fascinating.